we begin with this deadly out-of-control
wildfire in Northern California suddenly
exploded overnight the car fire burned
dozens of homes in the Reading area
north of Sacramento hundreds more are
threatened a bulldozer operator was
killed and three firefighters were
injured one officials says the fire is
taking down everything in its path
evacuation orders expanded quickly
overnight as the fire spread the chaotic
Exodus caused massive traffic jams as
thousands of people fled some are forced
to drive through the fire the car fire
is one of at least five major wildfires
burning in California
Joe Vasquez of our San Francisco CBS
station KPIX is in reading Joe good
morning good morning and you can see
that wall of flames here behind me on
the hillside looming over West reading
it was a frightening and chaotic night
last night as that fire just came raging
through city subdivisions the fury of
the car fire took the town of Redding by
surprise late Thursday as flames jumped
the Sacramento River and engulfed the
area reading is home to some 92 thousand
people this is that new normal that
unpredictability the large explosive
growth fires officials say a private
bulldozer operator was killed the
operator was working on an active
section of the car fire we're in the
process of notifying next of kin we can
confirm that we have additional
firefighters as night fell worried
homeowners watched the flames get closer
and closer oh my god everybody's like
panicking and going crazy and
everybody's just trying to leave
wind-whipped
flames made roads nearly impassable
evacuees quickly filled the highway out
of town with bumper-to-bumper traffic a
reading news station even had to
abruptly end its fire coverage we are
going to leave the station because it is
now unsafe to be here the fire destroyed
homes and an historic schoolhouse in the
nearby town of Shasta since it ignited
on Monday it has sports dozens of square
miles and is far from contained this
fire is extreme
dangerous and moving with no regard for
what's in its path the National Guard
has been called in to help with the
firefighting effort as well as
evacuations but Nora right now there's
not a lot of fire fighting taking place
they're focusing on trying to save some
lives
Joe Vasquez things